vous êtes sur France 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'Afrique à la une ce soir novembre 2012
novembre 2022 10 ans que les rebelles
lui-même 23 s'aiment la terreur dans
l'est de la République démocratique du
Congo décrire de guerre commis à grande
échelle des compris des exécutions au
sommaire des viols et des recrutements
de force des milliers de déplacés nous
entendrons les habitants de Goma très
inquiets à l'idée que les rebelles
reviennent dans la ville pour en parler
nous retrouverons Alain moukoura Linda
le porte-parole adjoint du gouvernement
rwandais son pays est régulièrement
accusé de soutenir la rébellion du M23
des poursuites judiciaires contre Alpha
Condé la jante au pouvoir en Guinée
poursuit l'ancien président ainsi que
180 au cadre et ancien ministre pour des
faits présumés de corruption nous irons
sur place dans ce journal
nous irons aussi au Sénégal au
l'opposant Ousmane Sonko était entendu
au tribunal de Dakar ce jeudi dans une
affaire de viol présumée une convocation
sous haute tension avec un gros
déploiement sécuritaire dans une dans la
capitale sénégalaise nous retrouverons
notre correspondante sur place
depuis novembre 2012 les rebelles lui M
23 sévissent dans l'Est de la RDC la
ville de Goma qui a été la première
prise par les rebelles aujourd'hui la
même rébellion est à quelques dizaines
de kilomètres de la grande capitale de
l'Est de la RDC qui est encore une fois
vit dans la crainte et l'incertitude on
les écoute
de voir qu'après 10 ans nous revenons
aussi que les départs avec les mêmes
rebelles les mêmes protagonistes
pourtant on était sûr qu'on avait
l'espoir de vivre la paix durable mais
hélas nous demandons à nos autorités de
pouvoir renforcer l'effectif des RDC
pour que l'option militaire puisse
mettre fin à ce cycle de violence s'il y
a des négociations ce n'est pas grave et
sinon qu'ils utilisent la force
l'essentiel pour nous et de retrouver la
paix nous avons besoin de reprendre nos
activités et que nos enfants grandissent
enfin dans la paix la sécurité
de multiples agressions du Rwanda et de
l'Ouganda
puissance essentiellement les États-Unis
d'Amérique la Grande-Bretagne la France
et les autres pays venant par la
présence manifestation
exprimée au monde entier notre album du
fait que nous connaissions d'injustice
et des discrimination internationales
[Musique]
nous retrouvons Alain moukoura Linda
porte-parole adjoint du gouvernement
rwandais merci d'être avec nous sur
France 24 dites-nous 10 ans que le M23
s'aime la tireur dans l'Est de la RDC
vous avez entendu ces habitants de Goma
la République démocratique du Congo
ainsi qu'un groupe d'experts des Nations
Unies ainsi que Romain humain vous
accuse de soutenir le M23 je vous le
demande votre pays le Rwanda est-il en
guerre dans l'Est de la RDC
Rwanda n'est pas en guerre dans l'Est de
la RDC donc venez de le dire ça fait 10
ans mais c'est 10 ans ou on a constaté
malheureusement de la part du
gouvernement congolais de la RDC un
manque de volonté politique un manque de
volonté pour politique pour exécuter à
la lettre les décisions qui ont été
prises lors des différents processus de
différents négociations et d'un
négociation en Afrique du Sud de
négociations en Éthiopie dernièrement il
y a une des processus de nairobie et de
Luanda mais aucune action concrète du
gouvernement congolais dans ce sens sur
le terrain ne peut à ce jour être
démontré par ce dernier mais eux ils
demandent monsieur moukor eux ils
demandent que vous cessiez votre soutien
au M23 que leur répondez-vous
précisément sur cette sur cette question
pas besoin de soutenir le M23 le M23 est
composé par des Congolais même s'il part
qu'il n'y awanda cela ne veut pas dire
qu'ils doivent nécessairement être aidé
par le Rwanda il y a eu une occasion qui
a été par exemple que je qualifierais
d'occasion rater il y a 10 ans ou en
2013 le M23 a été défait une partie en
Ouganda une autre partie au Rwanda et au
Rwanda ils ont été désarmés et placés au
plus loin de la frontière pourquoi
est-ce que à ce moment-là ou le
gouvernement congolais était imposé de
force n'a pas voulu négocier avec sa
propre population dernièrement son
revenu d'Ouganda et qui se sont
installés encore une fois en RDC on a
appris avec le gouvernement congolais il
y a eu des résultats qui apparemment
n'ont pas été appliqués puisque la
guerre a repris alors vous il ne vous a
pas échappé qu'entre temps il y a eu un
changement de régime évidemment au Congo
et pas au Rwanda
donc c'est finalement vous j'ai envie de
dire vous êtes toujours les mêmes
interlocuteurs à Kigali alors dites-nous
condamnez-vous par exemple l'offensive
du M23 dans le retour là depuis deux
semaines
fait par que ce soit par le MP3 ou par
d'autres groupes rebelles n'oubliez pas
qu'on parle de plus de 130 groupes
rebelles dans l'Est de la RDC tout
groupement militaire
qui euh
combat l'armée congolaise qui
maltraitent la population nous voilà la
population qui est en train de fuir nous
voyons la population qui souffre depuis
10 ans tout cela est condamnable mais
c'est pas une raison que le Rwanda soit
toujours pris comme bouc émissaire par
rapport aux échecs internes du
gouvernement congolais aujourd'hui
dernièrement le 25 du
du mois passé on a vu le porte-parole du
gouvernement congolais cette fois-ci
prendre la communauté internationale à
témoin pour dire que si dans la région
il y a pas la paix il y aura pas
d'élection or nous avons encore 12 à 15
mois pour qui est ces élections pourquoi
au lieu de mettre toutes ses efforts
tous les efforts possibles à régler ce
problème on commence à nous parler de la
non tenue des élections alors qu'il y a
5 ans il y a eu les élections et la
était toujours en ébullition que dire de
l'état des sièges qui a été déclaré il y
a un an aujourd'hui
est-ce que il y a une amélioration il y
a une détérioration tout cela pour dire
que si ça marche pas c'est à cause du
Rwanda et j'ai même été étonné hier soir
en écoutant son Excellence le Ministre
de l'affaire étranger imputer l'échec de
la Monusco au fait que l'armée rwandaise
est mieux équipée que l'armée onusienne
aujourd'hui on fait c'est maintenant
qu'on c'est comme cela qu'on veut
expliquer la faiblesse des résultats
durant ces 22 ans de la Monusco je pense
que
ça parlons justement de ça et on sait
que les troupes kenyana ont été envoyés
dans l'Est pour aider justement l'armée
congolaise a contingent rwandais sera
positionné le long de la frontière avec
la RDC mais vous ne ferez pas partie de
ces troupes parce que la RDC a refusé
pour expliquer
dites-nous justement quel va être les
contours de la de cette troupe rwandaise
qui seront positionnés le long de la
frontière de la RDC
je dirais d'abord mieux vaut tard que
jamais heureusement que
là comme je l'ai dit au début de ma
réponse on ne paye pas concrètement des
décisions être mise en pratique c'est
une très bonne chose que aujourd'hui on
commence à constituer une force
conjointe comme cela était décidé il y a
quelques temps un aérobie et le Rwanda
est prêt à donner l'aide qui lui sera
demandé l'armée congolaise le
gouvernement congolais ne veut pas que
le que les troupes rwandaise fasse
partie
de cette arme conjointe on est d'accord
on prend acte c'est pas grave c'est pas
un problème le plus important pour le
Rwanda est que cette armée soit mise sur
pied et qu'il puisse ramener la paix tel
que le Rwanda a toujours là toujours
voulu parce que un Congo laisse du Congo
qui est stable c'est ça a un intérêt
énorme pour tous les pays limitrophes de
ce grand pays et alors dites nous est-ce
que
l'expulsa est-ce que ça signe ou ça
marque la fin de la voix diplomatique ou
est-ce qu'il est encore une chance pour
la voix diplomatique
il y aura toujours une chance pour la
voix diplomatique comme on l'a toujours
dit comme le gouvernement rendu a
toujours dit
l'escalade c'est de la part du
gouvernement congolais c'est pas de la
part du gouvernement rwandais prendre
des décisions que je qualifierais de
spectaculaire qui ne résorbent rien sur
le terrain ne sert à rien si le Rwanda
avait voulu aussi aller en escalade il
aurait fait et il aurait pris la même
décision vous l'avez vu c'est pas ce qui
s'est passé donc le fait que
l'ambassadeur soit expulsé c'est pas une
bonne chose mais heureusement
l'ambassade n'est pas les deux
ambassades ne sont pas fermés donc les
canaux de communication sont toujours là
et puis vous avez remarqué que il y a
aussi les mystères du président de
l'officier de liaison angolais
qu'attendez-vous de lui précisément
on passe à la Guinée où on passe à la
Guinée ou les militaires au pouvoir ont
décidé d'engager des poursuites
judiciaires à l'encontre d'Alpha Condé
l'ancien président renversé par un coup
d'État en 2021 ainsi que plus de 180 au
cadres et anciens ministres sont accusés
notamment de fait présumés de corruption
notre correspondant à en Guinée Malik
Diakité nous en dit plus
ils sont tous poursuivis pour des faits
présumées de corruption enrichissement
illicites à blanchiment d'argent faux et
usage de fond en écriture publique
détournement de dernier public et
complicité dans ce document signé par le
ministre de la Justice Charles Alphonse
white le président de chez Alpha Condé
et 187 autres ancien cadre de son régime
devront faire face à la justice parmi
eux certains sont déjà en prison
notamment l'ancien Premier ministre
Ibrahima Kassory Fofana Mohamed Diana
ancien ministre de la Défense Amadou
Damaro Camara ancien président de
l'Assemblée nationale le même document
on dit que les comptes bancaires sont
gilets ce n'est pas la première fois que
des poursuites sont engagés par les
militaires au pouvoir contre l'ancien
président Alpha Condé en mai dernier il
avait été mis en cause pour des faits
présumés notamment d'assassinat de
tortues enlèvement et viol suite à des
plantes du Front national pour la
défense de la Constitution une coalition
qui s'était fortement proposer à son
troisième mandat pour rappel l'ancien
président guinéen Alpha Condé est en
Turquie depuis mai dernier pour des
raisons médicales
on passe au Sénégal ou ce jeudi Marc le
retour au tribunal d'Ousmane Sonko
l'opposant sénégalais était entendu dans
une affaire de viol présumée une
convocation sous haute tension avec un
gros déploiement des forces de l'or dans
la capitale sénégalaise pour parer à
d'éventuelles débordements l'opposant a
pu être auditionné et rentrer chez lui
en milieu d'après-midi correspondance à
Dakar de Sarah Sakho
Ousmane Sonko est arrivé au tribunal un
peu avant midi en heure locale il a fait
une entrée très discrète les
journalistes qu'il attendait nombreux
devant le palais de justice non
d'ailleurs pu l'apercevoir les entrées
sont complètement bouclés autour de ce
tribunal il faut montrer patte blanche
pour son approcher et de manière
générale les forces de l'ordre sont
massivement déployées aux axes
stratégiques de la ville mais également
autour du domicile de l'opposant c'est
donc la première audition sur le fond
d'Ousmane Sonko depuis le début de cette
affaire depuis près de deux ans donc
dans cette affaire qu'il oppose à Hadji
SAR une jeune femme qui l'accuse de viol
répété et de menaces de mort l'audition
c'est bien déroulée selon l'opposant qui
a posté dans quelques mots à sa sortie
de l'audition sur les réseaux sociaux je
vous propose d'écouter son avocat c'est
très très bien comporté et à excellent
répondu aux questions aux clients ont
été posées
mais vous me direz qu'a-t-il dit je ne
peux et je ne saurais vous le dire et
pourquoi je suis tenu par le secret de
l'instruction il est donc calme Olympia
il est d'une sérénité déconcertante mais
il reste confiant et a toujours dit que
c'est un complot ça va ma orchestré par
qui vous savez et le coût a avorté et le
complot a été éventré la veille de cette
convocation
Ousmane Sonko avait appelé
au calme les invitants à ne pas
l'accompagner au tribunal de son côté la
majorité au pouvoir a tenu un point
presse pour appeler l'État à prendre ses
responsabilités pour que les Sénégalais
puissent vaquer ce jeudi à leurs
occupations
et c'est ainsi que nous refermons ce
journal de l'Afrique merci à tous ceux
qui nous ont suivi et en particulier
ceux de Kinshasa qui gagne en passant
par Goma restez avec nous car
l'actualité continue sur France 24
[Musique]